[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten
guten abend hohe gipfel wollen bestiegen
werden
g20-gipfel am wochenende in rom danach
weltklimagipfel in glasgow us präsident
joe biden sitzt gerade im flieger nach
europa mit etwas verspätung aber
zumindest der hoffnung dass er der welt
investitionen in den klimaschutz
ankündigen kann mehr ist es vorerst
nicht beiden musste bis zum abflug
ringen um sein billionen paket für
soziales und klima und von dem hängt
auch seine präsidentschaft ab claudia
bertz berichtet
ein guter tag selbst beschwörung am
frühen morgen er weiß er muss liefern
vor dem g20-gipfel am wochenende und dem
klimagipfel danach er darf nicht mit
leeren händen kommen muss beweisen dass
amerika es ernst meint mit den großen
ankündigungen beim kampf gegen den
klimawandel und einer neuen
sozialpolitik und er braucht dafür ist
eine große gesetzespakete die noch
durchs parlament müssen
hier geht es um wettbewerbsfähigkeit
oder selbstgefälligkeit darum chancen
auszubauen statt sie zu verwehren es
geht darum die welt zu führen oder von
aller welt überholt zu werden
biden im kongress noch einmal
unterstreicht er die dringlichkeit der
beiden gigantischen gesetzespakete
seinen eigenen leuten denn die feinde
sitzen in der eigenen partei streiten
über details seine präsidentschaft hinge
davon ab schärft er ihnen ein
und hier umgeht es maßnahmen gegen den
klimawandel
massive investitionen in saubere
erneuerbare energien und dabei
gleichzeitig hunderttausende jobs
schaffen bis 2030 die emissionen um gut
50 prozent senken
die mittelschicht fördern mit
bezahlbaren kindergarten
steuererleichterungen für familien und
für geringe einkommen
die krankenversicherung ausbauen und
billiger machen
und eine klimafreundliche erneuerung der
infrastruktur straßen brücken
wasserleitungen digitalisierung
ist die agenda für die 81 millionen
amerikaner bei den
präsidentschaftswahlen gestimmt haben
wenn wir diese investitionen machen dann
ist das amerikanische volk nicht
aufzuhalten uns gehört die zukunft über
owen gefühlt
ob er damit seine demokraten hinter den
gesetzen versammeln kann die pakete
wurden schon geschrumpft inhaltlich und
finanziell kosten 175 millionen dollar
rund halb so viel wie geplant die
opposition ruft sozialismus
millionen von dollar eine riesige
aufblähung der regierung und noch mehr
inflation das wird teuer für alle
amerikaner
doch es ist nicht weniger ist das
herzstück von beiden vorhaben wenn es
scheitert sieht es düster aus für die
kongresswahlen im nächsten jahr er
fliegt ab zum gipfel wo er der welt
versichern will was er angekündigt hat
amerika ist berg
nachfrage bei elmar theveßen in
washington immer davon ob beiden sein
paket durch bringt im kongress wird ja
am ende auch abhängen wie viel amerika
für den klimaschutz tut das hat also für
die ganze welt bedeutung wird das jetzt
klappen
ich glaube ja denn die die kritisch
demgegenüber standen die waren
unmittelbar beteiligt will man beispiele
nennen beim kampf gegen den klimawandel
wollte man eigentlich ursprünglich auch
strafen verhängen gegen große
unternehmen die sich weigern damit
einzusteigen jetzt setzt man eher auf
anreize auf steuererleichterung und das
gesamtpaket mag manchen zweimal noch
nicht groß genug sein aber allein
555 milliarden dollar für anreize im
kampf gegen den klimawandel das ist so
viel dass sozusagen selbst kritiker in
den umweltverbänden in den usa der
einstieg in wirklich einen wechsel in
den usa auf klimafreundliche politik
damit gelingen könnte wenn es durch den
kongress kommt und das gesamtpaket in
kombination mit den anderen paketen
könnten die amerikanische gesellschaft
tatsächlich ein stück weit
transformieren da ist so viel drinnen
wirtschaftlich sozial aber auch
umweltpolitisch das ist etwa die
größenordnung erreicht wie in den 60er
jahren die sogenannte great society von
präsident johnson also es wäre eine
große transformation amerikas und damit
natürlich auch ein signal an den rest
der welt auch an die europäer da auch
selber mitzumachen
dankeschön du machst dich dann auch auf
den weg richtung gipfel da sehen wir
dich sicher wieder dankeschön mit
verschiedenen konkreten folgen des
klimawandels werden wir uns später in
der sendung noch beschäftigen nun
zunächst zur aktuellen corona lage dass
die infektionszahlen jetzt nach den
herbstferien steigen würden damit konnte
man rechnen seit gestern machte die
inzidenz sogar einen sprung nach oben
das ließ heute durchaus aufhorchen
genauso wie die warnung der
krankenhausärzte dass auch in diesem
winter mit engpässen in den kliniken zu
rechnen sei kamran safari an bündelt den
stand der dinge
draußen zeigt sich der herbst mit
eindrucksvollen farben die temperaturen
fallen die korona zahlen steigen rasant
an bundesweit springt die inzidenz auf
130,2 vor fünf monaten lag sie noch bei
40 28 1037 neuinfektionen meldet das lka
heute 11 1960 mehr als vor einer woche
auf der isolierstation der uniklinik
bonn bereitet man sich auf die vierte
welle vor von fünf sogenannten isolier
zellen sind alle belegt wir sehen dass
wir wieder zunehmend personen auch
stationär betreuen müssen das ist nicht
nur auf der intensivstation aber auch
dort und das problem ist dass wir jetzt
ungeimpfte jüngere patienten haben die
krank werden in der natur des jüngeren
menschen liegt es natürlich dass sie
länger durchhalten länger krank sind und
damit unsere intensiv kapazitäten länger
in anspruch nehmen es werden also wieder
mehr die mit schweren verläufen ins
krankenhaus müssen nicht nur in bonn die
zahl der korona patienten auf
intensivstationen
liegt bundesweit heute bei 1808 experten
befürchten einen anstieg der
intensivpatienten
unsere sorge ist schon dass wir wiederum
um die 3000 haben werden und das
bedeutet eine einschränkung für die
regelversorgung das heißt dann werden
andere patientinnen und patienten auf
planbare operationen warten müssen eine
belastung also auch für die normale
stationen dort stieg die zahl der kugel
patienten innerhalb einer woche sogar um
40 prozent die hospitalisierung rate
liegt heute aktuell bei 3,31 noch weit
unter der im vergangenen winter aber die
situation ist dramatisch weil wir
zunehmend pflegepersonal verlieren die
menschen sind ausgepowert die können
nicht mehr arbeiten die überlastung
zehrt an den nerven und sie sind es zum
teil auch leipzig ab zu ackern für
ungeimpfte denn 95 prozent der patienten
auf den intensivstationen sind
ungeimpfte ein problem laut einer forsa
befragung im auftrag des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums
wollen sich nur zwei prozent der nicht
geimpften auf jeden fall noch impfen
wir müssen den skeptikern klarmachen
dass derjenige der sich nicht impfen
lässt mit seinem leben spielt und mit
dem seiner mitmenschen diese erkrankung
ist kein schnupfen ist keine grippe
dieser erkrankung tötet und daher bleibt
das wichtigste die impfquote muss
steigen
also wie ist die lage das fragen wir
professor clemens wentner infektiologe
und stefan der münchen klinik in
schwabing schimmerten abend
forschungsprofessor rentner sie neigen
nicht zum alarmismus deshalb ganz
nüchtern mal die frage was löst diese
incidents 130 bei ihnen aus wie
besorgniserregend
finden sie dass
sich teile schon die sorgen die in ihrem
filmbeitrag genannt wurden es ist so wir
hatten schon höhere instanzen gesehen
allerdings haben wir auch ein problem
weil die betten in den letzten monaten
auch sozusagen weniger geworden sind
insbesondere intensivbetten wir haben
knapp 4000 intensivbetten weniger als im
januar 20 21 und das führt vor augen
dass wir mit den betten auch gut
haushalten müssen und die patienten
brauchen eine lange pflege das hat herr
professor straßburg gesagt sie sind
länger auf intensivstationen weil sie
jünger als investor stattliche alter
liegt bei 50 jahren der patient und sind
90 95 prozent geimpft
die warnung leute lautet heute die lage
in den krankenhäusern könne eben genauso
eng werden wie letzten winter wie
erleben sie das in ihrer klinik ist
diese warnung auch eine die sie
aussprechen ganz konkret man ja durchaus
es ist so dass wir kommen sehr konkret
50 kubik patienten versorgen ein drittel
liegt auf intensivstationen wir haben
aber bereits einen pandemie stationen
eröffnet
und es ist so dass wir auch schon knapp
knapp retten intensivbetten haben im
einzelfall müssen patienten auch in
umliegende kliniken verlegt werden das
ist eine situation wie wir sie derzeit
in südbayern auch sehr stark erleben und
wir haben doch nicht das ende der
pandemie vor uns der winter ist noch vor
uns liegen das heißt wir werden noch
mehr fälle sehen gut 66 prozent
impfquote da stehen wir jetzt vielleicht
ein bisschen mehr aber voran geht es ja
kaum noch und die die bisher ungeimpft
sind das klang gerade schon ansagen zu
zwei dritteln dass sie sich vor ist
jedenfalls auch nicht impfen lassen
werden das ist diese umfrage die heute
herauskam müssen wir mit diesem stand
leben professor rentner oder was ist ihr
eindruck ist da noch was drin also die
hoffnung stirbt zuletzt wir möchten auch
hier noch kämpfen um diese menschen wir
möchten sie überzeugen es gab ja gerade
diese woche ein sehr prominentes
beispiel ein fußballer der die frage
gestellt hat ob es zusagen nicht lang
zeit probleme bei impfungen gibt wir
müssen hier vielleicht noch besser
aufklären ich sage hier sei eindeutig
wir wissen sehr genau dass cupid
langfristige folgen hat stichpunkt longo
witt mindestens zehn prozent beim impfen
kennen wir diese langfristigen
nebenwirkungen nicht also hier nochmal
der aufruf wirklich in sich zu gehen man
darf von impfen auch an sich zunächst
denken aber bitte auch an die mit
menschen die einfach keine chance haben
sich erfolgreich impfen lassen zu können
ich betreue viele leukämiepatienten die
vor dem corona virus wie das kaninchen
vor der schlange stehen und hier glaube
ich ist auch eine gewisse solidarität
gefragt von uns allen
letzte frage nach nun er hat man immer
wieder von impft durchbrüchen gab gerade
ein prominentes beispiel das bekannt
wurde edmund stoiber doppelt geimpft
jetzt corona positiv wie schätzen sie
die gefahr ein genügt es die über
70-jährigen mit dieser dritten booster
impfung zu versorgen die stiko empfiehlt
genau das ist am anfang bei den über
70-jährigen anzufangen die
gesundheitsministerkonferenz erlaubt ist
ja bereits ab dem sechzigsten lebensjahr
habe ich wünsche mir dass wir ähnlich
wie es soll die sache betrachten in
israel gibt es keine altersbeschränkung
und dieses angebot hilft wir wissen doch
eine dritte impfung wird der
schutzfaktor um den faktor 20 erhöht
also man ist einfach besser gegen coop
19 geschützt
dankeschön professor rentner nach
münchen und hier haben wir jetzt weitere
nachrichten können sogar
im fall der serie von drew schreiben mit
der unterschrift nsu 2.0 hat die
staatsanwaltschaft frankfurt am main
anklage erhoben der in berlin im mai
festgenommene mann soll vom sommer 2008
zehn an 116 drohbriefe und mails an
behörden und personen des öffentlichen
lebens geschickt haben ausschließlich an
frauen in anspielung auf die
rechtsextremistische mordgruppe nsu
wurden die adressaten in wüst beschimpft
und bedroht der angeklagte bestreitet
die vorwürfe
großbritannien hat am abend die
französische botschafterin einbestellt
anlass ist dass frankreich im streit mit
london über fischereirechte im
ärmelkanal einen britischen kutter
festgesetzt hat ohne genehmigung sei das
boot in französischen gewässern
unterwegs gewesen so die regierung in
paris als enttäuschend und
unverhältnismäßig bezeichnete london die
maßnahme seit dem brett streiten beide
länder über fischerei lizenzen im
ärmelkanal paris beklagt dass die
britischen behörden französischen
fischern bisher nur 210 lizenzen für
ihre gewässer erteilt hätten nicht
genügend aus sicht der franzosen
auch im streit über die praxis regeln
für nordirland gibt es keine annäherung
bei einem staatsbesuch in irland hat
bundespräsident steinmeier nun eine
rasche einigung gefordert er warnte vor
rückschritten für den friedensprozess in
nordirland und würdigte in vertraulichen
treffen mit friedens akteuren deren
verdienste um versöhnung vor dem
hintergrund der laufenden
koalitionsverhandlungen fordert das
umweltbundesamt den schnellen abbau
klima und umweltschädlicher subventionen
zum beispiel der pendlerpauschale diese
beliefen sich laut einer studie 2018 auf
insgesamt mehr als 65 milliarden euro
durch den verzicht auf
steuervergünstigungen etwa für diesel
und auf mehrwertsteuer vorteile etwa für
tierische produkte seien mehreinnahmen
in zweistelliger milliardenhöhe möglich
dieses geld könne so das umweltbundesamt
in den klimaschutz investiert werden
in berlin ging heute die stille ag
arbeit zur bildung einer ampelkoalition
weiter während sich spd grüne und fdp
dem motto arbeiten und dichthalten
verschrieben haben werden woanders
wunden geleckt die cdu fragt sich wer
neuer vorsitzender werden soll und
wieviel basisvotum dabei möglich sein
darf die linke geht in klausur und
präsentiert sich wie meistens uneins das
wahlergebnis unter fünf prozent dass sie
im parlament vertreten ist verdankt sie
drei direktkandidaten
doch die schlappe bleibt vorerst ohne
konsequenzen andrea maurer aus leipzig
glaubt man diesen bildern soll es bei
der fraktionsklausur der linken in
leipzig auch um symbolische gesten gehen
in leipzig hat sören pellmann eins der
drei direktmandate geholt die eine linke
fraktion überhaupt erst möglich machen
und so gehen die abgeordneten irgendwann
raus aus dem tagungshotel und sagen
danke die große politische geste aber
ist nach dem wahl-debakel ausgeblieben
niemand hat seinen rücktritt angeboten
parteispitze bleibt fraktionsspitze
bleibt neuaufstellung mit den alten die
gründe werden jenseits der handelnden
personen gesucht alter streit ungelöste
probleme als jemand der spitzenkandidat
gemeinsam mit janine wissler hut tragen
wir natürlich eine besondere
verantwortung ist unbestritten nur das
ist glaube ich sogar konsens sind der
partei dass die ursachen für unsere
niederlage nicht in den wahlkampf und
dem agieren der beiden spitzenkandidaten
gelegen dietmar bartsch wirkt genervt in
diesen tagen obwohl er und amira
mohammed ali am montag mit fast 77
prozent als fraktionsvorsitzende
bestätigt wurden dass die wiederwahl
nicht nur glanz moment war zeigt sich an
seiner dünnhäutigkeit es hat im vorfeld
die aufforderung an ihn gegeben jetzt in
würde platz zu machen und überlegungen
dass die fraktionsvorsitzenden nur
übergangsweise im amt sind
es gibt einige die irgendwelche
übergänge formulieren das ist großer
unsinn ist heute gewählt worden unsere
ordnung sieht zwei jahre vor und das ist
der stand alles andere ist dummes
geschwätz einzelner es scheint auch ein
machtkampf zwischen partei und fraktion
denn es ist parteichefin hennig will so
die sagt alles sei auf bewährung auch
der fraktionsvorsitz und zwar für
anderthalb jahre übergang also sind
beine gewählt die geschäftsordnung der
fraktion sagte auf zwei jahre ich sage
der parteitag wird anfangen 2029 das
sind anderthalb jahren eine empfehlung
treffen
wie die fraktionen sich nur aufstellen
soll damit wir unsere spitzenpersonal
was 2025 eine wahl wieder gewinnen soll
auf tatsächlich zusammen passt was die
fraktionsvorsitzenden mitbringen nach
leipzig ist ein positionspapier
es geht um konsequente rückbesinnung auf
den sozialen markenkern gerade einmal
fünf prozent der arbeiterinnen und
arbeiter haben die linke gewählt für
sahra wagenknecht die ihr anklage buch
gegen eine sogenannte lifestyle linke
mitten im wahlkampf veröffentlicht hat
ist das papier eine bestätigung ihrer
these es gibt eine strömung in der
partei das stimmt die auch er
sich so orientiert dass wir eben in den
modernen bogen akademischen debatten gut
dastehen und ich denke dass man jetzt
nach dem doch eine richtung die partei
in den letzten jahren sehr stark geprägt
hat und sich das in wahlergebnissen
nicht ausgezahlt hat und wir doch also
immer schwächer geworden sind doch viele
so sehen das können wir nicht
weitermachen
richtungsstreit mancher die wagenknecht
jetzt in der defensive sieht sind vor
den kopf gestoßen das positionspapier
wird sofort an die presse durchgestochen
zur abstimmung kommt es nicht
zerstrittenheit da sind sich hier fast
alle einig war ein hauptgrund für das
wahldebakel und trotzdem bleibt auch da
anscheinend erst mal alles beim alten
sizilien wird in diesen tagen von
sturzfluten heimgesucht das mittelmeer
zur hurrikan region der klimawandel
führt weltweiter zu dass wir künftig
mehr gefährliche unwetter erleben werden
auch in gemäßigten breiten die
erinnerung an die schrecken im sommer
immer und im erftal sind gegenwärtig die
folgen des klimawandels damit wird sich
die weltklimakonferenz beschäftigen denn
der mensch muss sich wappnen gegen das
was er selbst angerichtet hat wir wollen
uns in den nächsten tagen bevor es in
glasgow losgeht mit verschiedenen
aspekten des klimawandels beschäftigen
und haben heute katja honnefer bei uns
im studio schwimmen und katja so
unwetter gab es jetzt immer schon aber
es ist ja doch forschungsstand dass die
an heftigkeit an häufigkeit zunehmen
werden und dass eben auch in europa auch
in europa zum beispiel besonders am
mittelmeer da ist es ja im sommer sehr
oft sehr heiß und sehr trocken und auch
das mittelmeer wasser ist oft sehr waren
das bietet dann die energie dass sich
dort kräftige gewitter entwickeln und
dann eben so was wie ein haarig eine
ähnliche situation dieser medical dem
wir jetzt ganz aktuell beobachten über
dem mittelmeer aber auch in deutschland
gibt es untersuchungen darüber dass die
starkregen ereignisse gegenüber den
dauerregen ereignissen zu nehmen das ist
also viel häufiger in kurzer zeit sehr
heftig schüttet anstatt über längere
zeit nur wenig was ja angenehmer lehrer
starkregen das ist ein problem
zunehmende hitze phasen das andere
problem und das sogar in einem land wie
bei uns hier in deutschland besonders im
sommer in den städten da wird es
wirklich sehr ungemütlich heiß betrifft
vor allen dingen kranke ältere auch die
kleinen kinder deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass wir die städte klima
resilient umbauen also das wasser in den
städten halten dafür sorgen dass die
flächen entsiegelt und begrünt werden
und dass es frischluftschneisen gibt die
erderwärmung nimmt zu dadurch steigen
die meeresspiegel und dazu hast du uns
auch grafisch was mitgebracht genau dazu
schauen wir noch etwas zurück in der
geschichte denn der meeresspiegel steigt
auch schon bei uns an der nordseeküste
seit
1843 ist der in cuxhaven bereits um 42
cm gestiegen und könnte bis zum ende des
jahrhunderts um einen weiteren meter
steigen die nordseeküste wird sich so
mehr und mehr ins landesinnere fressen
und irgendwann werden dann auch hamburg
und bremen einfach verlaufen
was heißt ja irgendwann über was für
eine zeitliche dimension sprechen wir da
weiß moment kein mensch aber tatsächlich
könnte es schon in den nächsten
jahrzehnten gefährlich werden ja und
deshalb heißt das jetzt natürlich erst
mal kurzfristig deiche bauen solche
notwendigen schutzmaßnahmen können
allerdings nur bedingt helfen und das
zeigt uns christina elsner aus unserer
zdf.umwelt redaktion
sie ist schon jetzt vom steigenden
meeresspiegel betroffen die hansestadt
hamburg die erwärmung der meere
vergrößert das wasservolumen die pegel
steigen eine folge heftige sturmfluten
beate ritter ist meereswissenschaftlerin
an der uni hamburg sie erforscht den
umgang der bevölkerung mit den
wetterextremen die an der nordseeküste
immer häufiger auftreten für die
hamburger sk waren die in erster linie
erstmal sturmflut also da wird sowas
gleichgesetzt was habe ich erlebt was
kann ich bislang können schutzmauern die
sturmfluten noch abwehren doch die
treibhausgaskonzentration in der
atmosphäre nimmt zu so wird das
meerwasser noch wärmer und lässt die
pegel weiter ansteigen hinzu kommt das
wasser der abschmelzenden eismassen
schon jetzt taut der grönland eispanzer
dadurch steigt der globale meeresspiegel
jährlich 0,7 millimeter an auch in der
antrag des taut das eis wissenschaftler
erwarten bis zum ende des jahrhunderts
ein sogenanntes extremereignis
beim extremereignis muss man einfach
davon ausgehen dass alle gletscher
abgeschmolzen sind dass alle arktis und
antarktis eismassen abgeschmolzen sind
und dieses wasser dass es praktisch zu
geschlossen auf den meeresspiegel
das würde dann bedeuten der globale
meeresspiegel könnte um mehr als sieben
meter ansteigen schutzmauern deiche und
andere abwehrmaßnahmen können aber nicht
unendlich gebaut werden der grund die
kosten
in großbritannien gibt es in einigen
regionen schon jetzt keinen küstenschutz
mehr einen küsten ingenieur bringt es
auf den punkt
unser kostenmanagement plan sieht vor
dass wir in den nächsten 50 bis 100
jahren auf über 500 kilometern küste
sämtliche schutzmaßnahmen einstellen in
der folge werden einige kommunen
landeinwärts umgesiedelt werden müssen
den ärmeren ländern fehlt dafür meist
das geld und die inselstaaten haben
keinen raum für die umsiedlungen der
bewohner so ist der weltweite
küstenschutz nur befristet umsetzbar
schutzmaßnahmen bedeuten vor allem zeit
zu kaufen es gibt keinen schutz der ewig
hält man zum beispiel eine mauer dann
muss die nachkommende generationen hin
etwa 50 jahren entscheiden erneuern sie
diese mauer oder geben sie die mauer auf
und überlassen das land dem ozean
risiko die fakten und erkenntnisse
liegen auf den tisch
die frage ist allerdings wie viel
konkrete konsequenzen beim gipfel daraus
gezogen werden katja es wird ja wohl
nicht reichen sich jetzt nur anzupassen
an den klimawandel das wichtigste ist
der klimaschutz wir müssen natürlich
beides im auge behalten aber vor allen
dingen die treibhausgasemissionen senken
dass wir das top thema natürlich seien
in glasgow vielen dank hat ja für den
besuch im wetterbericht geht es nachher
nochmal um die situation am mittelmeer
dankeschön und hier geht es jetzt weiter
mit den nachrichten gundula gause
der deutsche arbeitsmarkt trotzt weiter
der korona pandemie im oktober sind
sogar so viele menschen in
sozialversicherungspflichtigen
arbeitsverhältnissen wie noch nie seit
der wiedervereinigung
die bundesagentur für arbeit meldet
aktuell 2 millionen
377.000 menschen ohne job das sind
88.000 weniger als im september die
quote sinkt auf 5,2 prozent im vergleich
zum vorjahr sind
383.000 menschen weniger arbeitslos
die inflationsrate in deutschland steigt
und steigt aktuell mit 45 prozent auf
den höchsten stand seit 28 jahren und
mehrere ökonomen erwarten dass die
inflation weiter anziehen wird dagegen
bewertet die europäische zentralbank die
hohe inflation als vorübergehend valerie
haller wie gefährlich ist die hohe
inflation de facto naja wenn es nach der
ezb geht es dass nur ein spuckte er
irgendwann demnächst vorbei sein wird
die zeitweise niedrigere mehrwertsteuer
die höheren energiepreise die
lieferengpässe all das treibt die
inflation aktuell an sollte sich aber
laut den europäischen währungshütern
kommendes jahr legen sie sind deutlich
optimistischer als andere notenbanken
großbritannien könnte schon kommenden
monat die zinsen anheben um die
inflation in den griff zu bekommen und
auch die amerikanische notenbank denkt
über höhere zinsen nach in der eurozone
ist man davon noch meilenweit entfernt
aber es gibt auch volkswirte die die
inflationsgefahren ganz anders
einschätzen als die ezb ja die gibt es
sie meinen dass wir erst mal mit einer
höheren inflation leben müssen das sind
ihre argumente die klimapolitik gibt es
nicht zum nulltarif da fallen höhere
steuern und abgaben an was energie
dauerhaft teurer macht um lieferengpässe
zu vermeiden verlagern unternehmen teile
ihrer produktion zurück nach europa und
auch das könnte produkte teurer machen
lange haben die meisten volkswirte ins
gleiche horn wie die ezb gestoßen aber
jetzt dreht sich die stimmung und die
skeptiker scheint langsam die oberhand
zu gewinnen
vielen dank valerie in unserem heute
journal update spricht wulf schmiese
später mit dem schweizer volkswirt
markus will von der universität st
gallen über die hohe inflation
der facebook konzern gibt sich einen
neuen namen
später soll die dachgesellschaft von
facebook und instagram künftig heißen
facebook gründer zuckerberg will damit
auf sein neues mega projekt einer neuen
virtuellen umgebung namens metallbauers
aufmerksam machen
rund 100 kilometer südlich von wien
lodert einer der bislang größten
waldbrände österreichs 100 hektar wald
stehen in flammen das entspricht einer
fläche von etwa 150 fußballfeldern
hunderte helfer und feuerwehrleute sind
im einsatz hubschrauber schütten
löschwasser in das unwegsame brandgebiet
so soll das überspringen der feuer auf
benachbarte waldgebiete verhindert
werden siedlungen sind nicht gefährdet
eine meldung vom tennis alexander zverev
steht im viertelfinale des atp-turniers
von wien nach einem etwas mühsamen sieg
gegen den australier alex tamino geht es
nun gegen den kanadier felix opéra
lassen
baum des jahres 2022 ist die rotbuche
vor allem der zustand der alt buchen sei
wegen der trockenheit kritisch erklärte
die stiftung baum des jahres allerdings
könnten jung buchen gut mit
klimaveränderungen umgehen also habe die
rotbuche es verdient zum zweiten mal
nach 1990 zum baum des jahres gewählt zu
werden
und im moment besonders schön wie
steigern wir die impfquote ist so etwas
denkbar wie ein lockdown für ungeimpfte
das fragt jetzt maybrit illner die eine
spannende runde bei sich versammelt hat
unbedingt dran bleiben ja nur 30 ist die
zeit für das heute-journal update wir
sagen bis morgens
[Musik]
guten abend über dem zentralen
mittelmeer hat sich jetzt tatsächlich
ein medical entwickelt also einer
haarigen ähnliche struktur über dem
mittelmeer über dem mediterranen mehr
wenn sie ganz genau hinschauen dann
sehen sie auf dem letzten bild sogar das
auge dieses medicus er wird jetzt in den
nächsten tagen aber nicht nach sizilien
weiter ziehen sondern so sagen ist
jedenfalls unsere prognosen er peilt er
die libysche küste an die sie hier sehen
können das ist eine gute nachricht denn
in sizilien hat es ja schon wahnsinnig
viel geregnet bei uns ist das wetter
immer noch von hochdruck geprägt aber
zum wochenende rücken die tiefs näher
und dann fällt auch mal regen nicht in
dieser nacht da bildet sich allenfalls
mal wieder etwas nebel und die
temperaturen sinken zum teil auf 2 bis 0
grad dann kann es also für bodenfrost
reichen meist aber ist es bei 11 bis 4
grad zu mild für bodenfrost und morgen
liegen die temperaturen im zähen nebel
nur sogar 8 bis 12 grad sonst werden 14
bis 16 und ganz im westen hier über den
ostfriesischen inseln aber auch am rhein
immerhin 17 bis 19 grad erreicht das
liegt am südwind und an viel sonne die
gibt es vor allen dingen im nordosten im
süden halten sich auch mal nebelfelder
ca von westen kommt schon dichtere
wolkenfelder heran und diese
wolkenfelder die werden uns dann am
wochenende erst etwas regen am samstag
bringen etwas weniger dann am sonntag
und der montag wenn ja für einige
feiertag ist allerheiligen regnet es
dann fast in ganz deutschland guten
abend